we had every reason to believe that
very soon uh matt gates and his crime
story would be back in the news and it
has just exploded back
into the news as gates associate joel
greenberg has now pleaded guilty
to six federal crimes including sex
trafficking of 18. exactly
the same crime that matt gates is being
investigated for now as a reminder
joel greenberg is a former tax collector
in florida seminole county
when we learned that this joel greenberg
decided to cooperate with investigators
greenberg's lawyer fritz sheller held a
hilarious press briefing
outside a courthouse and was straight up
asked did your client joel greenberg
introduce matt gates to underage girls
and check out
the then hilarious response from
greenberg's lawyer
did your client introduce nat gates to
any underage girls
or secularly
all right so i'm just going to let you
sit down there
and so i can look over your head and
ignore that question
i apologize i i just can't answer that
question i wasn't okay
i'm sorry that was that was a little
devious you're hiding down there below
and then
you zing that at me you know
yeah well it's looking very very bad
again six guilty pleas for joel
greenberg
sex trafficking a minor id theft
stalking and fraud and again remember
we learned a couple of weeks ago about a
letter sent by joel greenberg
to roger stone admitting that he
introduced matt gates to young girls
the six charges that greenberg has pled
guilty to
that's down from 33 charges we can only
imagine
it's six instead of 33 because of his
cooperation
which should be very scary for
congressman matt gates now on the sex
trafficking of a minor charge
the specific admission is that greenberg
admits to recruiting
women for commercial sex acts and paying
them more than seventy thousand dollars
between 2016 and 2018.
this is quickly getting very ugly for
matt gates and the only question now is
if and when gates will get indicted some
people called into the show last week
and said david of course gates is
getting indicted
i'm not sure and we'll get back to that
gates
has of course denied all wrongdoing
and on the friday show this week i'm
going to talk a little bit about
do sexual assault allegations matter
anymore in politics
do they matter to democrats but not to
republicans
or do they not matter at all at this
point in time we're going to talk about
that
friday maybe in this case republicans
should go
sort of with the trump riots defense
remember how trump has said
you know it wasn't real trumpists
rioting on january 6th that was like
antifa in disguise or something maybe
they go with
matt gates is really antifa in disguise
matt gates isn't really a republican
i don't know um it's important to
remember though that if you were joel
greenberg
you do not plead guilty even to the six
charges never mind 33
unless you really uh
are are had dead to rights by
investigators
you are setting yourself up at least
potentially for some serious prison time
by pleading guilty you do not plead
guilty to sex
trafficking of a minor unless you have
figured out a way to get leniency
by informing about others or something
now in all seriousness
are we going to get accountability
because for the last several weeks
gates almost seems emboldened by this
investigation
he's been running around doing these
america first
tour events promoting all sorts of
election lies writing off this entire
investigation as some kind of
partisan witch hunt which he
conveniently fails to mention
that the investigation started under
donald trump donald trump's
uh justice department started looking at
gates
but was stonewalled by political
appointees to the justice department
who were political appointees of donald
trump so it's a story with
so much of what's wrong right now
two-tier justice system
cronyism belligerent arrogance hypocrisy
double standards it's everything let's
now see if there is accountability uh i
hope that there is
last week or the week before i said i
don't know if gates is going to end up
indicted i got a few calls and even
played a voicemail from one caller who
said david
i don't know if you're just trying to be
balanced but of course matt gates is
getting indicted
i'm not so sure i'm not so sure uh
let's see if there is accountability it
seems as though the leash
is starting to tighten and we're going
to continue following it
we will have more coverage of the matt
gates fiasco
on our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show if you want to see
video
of my garden if you want to break from
politics
check out my really intense lettuce
yes l-e-t-t-u-c-e uh on my instagram
david.pakman find me there quick break
back after this
one of our sponsors today is covid
rescue
fund covid rescue fund is helping small
business owners
who have lost their businesses during
covid
there are over 100 000 small businesses
that have had to close their doors since
the pandemic began
there are many organizations out there
helping businesses who are still open
to stay afloat but covet rescue fund is
one of the few organizations working to
help businesses
reopen who have had to close covet
rescue fund
crowdsources funds to provide grants up
to one hundred thousand dollars
for these owners to create new
businesses
i would implore anyone in my audience to
help covet rescue fund in their mission
by donating at covidrescufund.org
all money that you give is going to the
mission
not to compensating people who work for
the organization
the founders of covid rescue fund are
big fans of the david pakman show
let's help them bring back as many small
businesses
as we can the link is right underneath
this video